I don't want to make it seem as though
minimalism is this very linear one size
fits-all method of living where there's
no real minimalist that would own XYZ
item
that's not what this is about
I love Joshua Becker's definition of
minimalism
the intentional promotion of the things
we most value and the removal of
anything that distracts us from it
I love it because the root here is
intentionality and so today as I share
these 20 items that I no longer own or
buy keep in mind that they're meant as
ideas rather than absolutes you may see
a few items on this list that you didn't
realize you could probably go without
and who knows you may even save some
money in the process for those of you
who are new hey I'm yesi on this channel
we talk about minimalism and slow and
intentional living so if those topics
sound interesting to you make sure to
hit that subscribe button so you won't
miss when I post a new video and also
give this video a thumbs up so YouTube
can recommend to you more positive
content like this first up is an
essential oil diffuser when I first
purchased one I thought that this was
going to be awesome and I was gonna love
it it was going to be super cozy because
the bubbling sound would be like
relaxing and the smells would be
soothing but it turned out to be
something that I didn't actually
gravitate to using very much because I'd
have to remember to put the stuff in it
and to refill it and particular brand
that I had got really gunky and icky and
I had to try to figure out how to
actually clean it appropriately and I
just I didn't like the idea of me
smelling all that junk that was sticking
to it like it was looking moldy you guys
um maybe it was just the brand that I
tried but yeah it wasn't for me next up
is coffee this one is definitely not an
absolute like I'm never gonna drink
coffee again sort of thing but I did
stop drinking coffee for the last couple
of months because I was noticing that my
teeth are starting to turn a bit yellow
so I took a break did some oil pulling
and then just reverted back to my other
teas and lattes if you watch my channel
for a bit you know that I love lattes
they're they're just my thing they're
something cozy that really makes me
happy in the morning and it's really
part of my daily routine usually I would
always drink decaf anyway because I'm
just really sensitive to the caffeine
and coffee is also really expensive so I
figured that if it's something that I'm
not really addicted to that I could go
without and not really miss it then I
may as well just take a break from it
but I get it I know that some people
they need their coffee and they cannot
go without it my husband's definitely
one of those people he's like yeah good
for you you do your thing I'm gonna
drink my coffee while I'm watching you
number three is cereals and breakfast
bars again I'm not like judging you if
you're doing these things but they're
just things that I have stopped doing I
get that they're convenient but they
really they're processed they have
basically no nutritional value and
they're just loaded with tons of sugar
so for me what I had personally been
doing when I had wanted to have
convenience is that I would meal prep
oatmeal jars that was basically I would
put things like Chia flax seeds carrots
or apples and that way I could make
something that was healthier that was
actually more nutritious while not
sacrificing the convenience so basically
what I would do is I would meal prep
these the night before I would go to
work so that in the morning my breakfast
would be ready so if you're wanting to
try to adopt some more healthier habits
consider finding a meal that you could
have the convenience with while at the
same time not sacrificing your
nutritional value number four is pajamas
those elegant classy ladies out there
are probably thinking that this is
horrific for saying but I was never
really one that would purchase pajamas
or that found a need for pajamas
basically what I use is my workout
shorts that I love I use them for
working out and I use them for sleeping
I know so it probably sounds horrible
and counterintuitive but I think that
they're pretty I feel comfortable in
them and I think that that's all that
really matters I think that confidence
looks so much better on a person and
what it is that they're wearing and
along those lines is swimsuits I don't
actually enjoy swimming I'm more of a
beach goer than a beach doer so if we do
go to the beach I don't really see a
need for a swimsuit if I don't plan on
getting in the water and I may but it's
not that frequent if it does happen so
what I use is basically my workout
shorts again I love these because
they're my workout short they're my
swimsuits they're my pajama shorts like
they're just my everything shorts so I
definitely didn't see a purpose in
having one item for an event that may
happen once a year if that number six is
chewing gum I used to be very addicted
to chewing gum I'd always have gum in my
mouth back when I was in high school I
had horrible eating habits I would drink
Coca-Cola every single day I'd eat those
Little Debbie snacks and those little
packaged little dessert snacks all the
time and when I started to try to do
away with those habits I my method was
kind of to do one thing at a time but
when I started to cut back on those
little snacks and the cookies and all
those things it was really hard for me
because I had gotten so used to eating
all the time just chewing I just wanted
to have something in my mouth it wasn't
that I was hungry I was just wanting to
eat something so I thought gum would be
the perfect solution but actually I
found that the more I would chew gum the
thirstier I would get and the more
Cravings I got I I don't know that
there's any like scientific studies on
them I definitely haven't done it or
looked into it but being that I haven't
chewed gum in years now I can definitely
say that for me when I do start to chew
gum again and I try it I'm thirstier and
I tend to crave more I don't know maybe
it's just in my mind but I don't really
chew gum anymore number seven is
freebies that entice any negative habits
or saying no to freebies like junk food
and candies don't get me wrong I'm not
trying to say that I never eat junk food
that's not the case but what I am trying
to say here is that sometimes it can be
really easy to say no to those things
that are actually costing you money up
front but it can be really easy to
overlook the things that are free
because you think to yourself well this
isn't costing me anything it's totally
free I'm benefiting from it but
sometimes all those freebies and little
goodie bags that you get are just
cluttering up your home they're making
it so that it's harder to find things
around your home or that you're having
to clean more things in your home and
when it comes to food items if you're
constantly receiving freebies like I had
an app on my phone that I was able to
have free snacks and junk food basically
at gas stations all the time for a while
I thought how awesome I'm getting all
this stuff for free but I'm harming the
environment because all these plastic
bottles that I'm throwing away all the
time with those snacks I'm loaded with
sugar again I get thirstier afterwards
and then I just feel icky I'd feel icky
after drinking these really sugary
loaded drinks and these gas station
pizzas that are just probably the most
horrible and nutritional value when it
comes to a pizza in general so I decided
that I would get rid of it and I deleted
that app and actually I haven't missed
it at all number eight is t-shirts like
fundraisers promotions and one-time
events I remember that when I watched
the documentary the true cost I was
bawling my eyes out I had no clue that
my purchases that I make in the name of
fashion were harming the lives of other
people and so what I do now when it
comes to t-shirts and things that I know
for a fact I will never wear again or
that I'm probably just gonna stash in my
closet somewhere is that if I am trying
to support a specific fundraiser where
they're selling T-shirts so I'll just
give them the money and then just ask
them not to order me a shirt and really
in general the same goes for any kind of
fundraisers where people are trying to
sell me a particular item that I know
for a fact I'm not going to be using
then I'll just give them the money and
say but don't order me that item number
nine is dryer sheets dryer balls and
fabric softener I actually used to use
all of these things when I eliminated
the dryer sheets I tried the dryer balls
and I thought they were cool and they
definitely lasted a while until one day
I they got lost somewhere I guess my
kids were playing with them and I just
went without them and realized that they
weren't really necessary either and in
terms of fabric softener I actually only
do this with our sheets but I don't use
fabric softener I use epsom salts with
essential oils this makes our sheets
smell delicious it makes them softer and
it's a non-toxic alternative
number 10 is drinks at restaurants water
is pretty much free at any restaurant
that I've ever been to and it will
probably be healthier than a great
majority of any of the drinks that
you'll find on the menu and if you feel
courageous enough to brush off some
funny looks you can take a little squirt
bottle of your favorite flavorings and
have some flavored water without having
to pay anything for it number 11 is
Q-tips you're probably gonna think that
this is gross but when I was a kid we
didn't have money for this type of stuff
and first of all I don't think we even
knew what this stuff was so my mom what
she would do is she would clean our ears
with bobby pins I'm not telling you to
try this at home don't puncture
anybody's eardrums but this is what I've
always done I've just always cleaned my
ears with a bobby pin cleaned it up and
use it again number 12 is alcohol and
social gatherings I say the social
Gatherings part because I was never
really much of an alcohol Drinker I've
actually never been drunk in my life and
I never really saw a point in it but at
the same time if I was at a restaurant
and a friend would drink I would join in
or if they would offer me something in
their home I would accept it but I'm
embarrassed to admit that I did that
only out of people pleasing because I
didn't want that person to feel left out
or to feel like I'm rejecting them or I
don't know I just I did it specifically
out of people pleasing Behavior I was
recently listening to the book
boundaries by Henry cloud and it just
was like an aha moment for me realizing
that people pleasing is not the loving
thing to do mind you again I was never
drunk from drinking alcohol I would only
drink one drink but still the fact that
I was accepting these things just to
make somebody else feel a certain way or
so that they would perceive me a certain
way was wrong in and of itself so I
would think things to myself like oh if
I say no thanks I don't drink they're
gonna think oh she's Miss Goody
Two-Shoes she doesn't drink or things
like that that I would just make up
stories in my mind so now if somebody
does offer me alcohol I just say no
thanks and anybody that's truly my
friend and cares about me will not feel
rejected by that and will be able to
respect that so if I actually do say yes
thank you it's going to be because I
want to not because I'm worried about
how somebody else is going to perceive
me number 13 is shaving products regular
Castile soap is basically my shaving
cream I no longer buy the depilatory
creams or disposable razors I have a
safety razor that I purchased about a
year ago for twenty dollars and a pack
of a hundred blades for eight dollars
which have lasted me well over a year
and will probably easily last until the
next year number 14 is disposable
napkins and paper towel rolls we
actually used to buy these items in the
past but I have two kiddos now and I'm
basically doing laundry just about every
other day if not every day I found it so
much easier now just to use cloth
napkins wash them and reuse them again
number 15 body washes creams toners face
serums and just any body care
paraphernalia essential oil Castile soap
is basically our body wash and no
surprise coconut oil is my lotion to my
surprise it wasn't until I actually got
rid of all those multi-step regimens and
face serums that my skin actually
cleared up so now what I basically use
is foaming Castile soap to wash my face
and then I just follow up with coconut
oil so sometimes I live on the wild side
and I just change up the essential oils
on the Castile soap like eucalyptus or
Citrus and um yeah that's about it
that's yesi living on the Wild Side
y'all number 16 floor cleaners foaming
cleaners basically any specialty
cleaners baking soda vinegar and Castile
so pretty much get any surface clean and
I can just add essential oils if I
really want a fresh scent without adding
any endocrine disruptors number 17 is
juices and soda I admit this is
something that took me years to be able
to accomplish because as I mentioned
back when I was in high school I was
heavily addicted to Coca-Cola I would
drink it every single day and I realized
that I wanted to change and I wanted
that habit to stop so that became my
first goal in order to stop drinking
Coca-Cola yes I kind of did switch over
to drinking fruit juices but I missed
that bubbling and it took me I would say
a good month or two to be able to kind
of no longer crave it and no longer
desire it it actually got to a point
where I just didn't have the palette for
that bubbly I just I don't even like it
anymore and then eventually after I beat
that addiction then I my next goal was
the juices and so I switched to drinking
teas and now that I've kind of
progressively gotten a little bit better
at room moving all of these like sugary
drinks I could basically drink water
with my meals and I'm perfectly content
but I definitely admit it took a while
to get me there number 18 is ice cream
I'm actually not a big ice cream fan I'm
more of a pastry fan than ice cream but
my husband and my kids are and what we
do in the summer is that we basically
freeze up some fruits and some ice cubes
with milk or coconut milk sometimes even
water just depending on what we're
making and then we just blend it all up
we have a Vitamix so yes it's meant for
making ice cream but you don't have to
have something fancy in order to make it
you can actually just blend it in your
blender put it in the freezer for a
little bit until it gets thick or making
popsicles as well which is something
that we tend to do and our kids love it
can be a great way to not only have a
healthier and cheaper version but also
it can be really a fun experience just
to try new recipes number 19 is bottled
water we have a Berkey filter that gives
us clean water here in the home but for
years my husband and I have been huge
fans of Yeti I'm not sponsored by Yeti
I'm just somebody that has used them and
purchased their things for years my
husband worked Works in construction in
the hot summer weather and in really
cold weather as well and I have been
working as a home nurse so I drive and I
don't have a refrigerator I don't have a
microwave for things and Yeti has been
the one brand that has been able to keep
my drinks cold or warm in either weather
and so basically I just fill up my water
bottle here in the home and then just
take it with me wherever I go so no need
to ever purchase bottled water and
lastly number 20 is lottery tickets I
actually haven't purchased one in
several years but I would say that
probably for the first two or three
years after I turned 18 I was doing that
constantly because I had just turned of
age and I was super excited that I could
buy them and I worked at a store that
would sell them so it was constantly in
front of me and I found that if I stayed
away for a while I would kind of just
forget about it but something would
happen the moment I would buy one and I
would win a ticket it just would keep me
hooked to try just one more time
thankfully I'd never really want
anything significant and I got bored of
it and I just stopped it all together
because at the time I was working for
minimum wage at as a cashier and I was
spending my hard-earned money for a
chance to win at something when if I had
really learned about money investing
money saving money then I could have put
it towards something I found that for me
buying tickets came from a scarcity
mindset from if I get lucky then I can
be rich
until I realized that if I make smarter
purchases and learn about investing
learn about saving then I can and ought
to make money
so that I can be financially free so
that I can spend more time with my
family so that I can give to other
people
so that I have less stress
I don't want to rely on a one in a
million chance that the lottery might
give to me
this is just my personal take on the
lottery it's definitely not an attack
for you if you do this every now and
then and you have the means for it it's
just that for me it was definitely a
mindset thing it was a scarcity I'm a
victim and I had to change that
mentality and put it back in my hands
that I can be responsible I can learn
how to manage money I can learn how to
save I can learn how to invest and I
don't have to rely on a chance that I
can work towards that so that's just my
personal take that's it for today's
video I thank you so much for watching
if you'd like to see any specific videos
let me know down in the comments below
or send me an email and let me know what
is one thing that you have stopped
purchasing that in the past you couldn't
see yourself without I'd love to hear
from you down in the comments below
until next time bye for now